President Trump publicly condemned
domestic violence one week after a top
aide resigned amid abuse allegations
staff secretary Rob Porter left the
White House following claims he abused
two ex-wives the president made eight
different public appearances before he
addressed the issue yesterday major
Garrett is at the White House major good
morning good morning pressure is
building inside the White House on chief
of staff John Kelly to explain
employment and clearance procedures on
his watch attempts by White House press
staff to do so have proven unsuccessful
and now a top house Republican is
investigating
I am totally opposed to domestic
violence of any kind everyone knows that
president Trump broke his silence on
domestic abuse a week after one of his
top aides Rob Porter resigned following
accusations of abuse by two ex-wives
charges Porter denies and it almost
wouldn't even have to be said so now you
hear it but you all know it the porter
scandal has left the West Wing
demoralized exhausted and mistrustful
one senior official said top White House
staff are quote not telling us the truth
chief of staff John Kelly and white
House Counsel Don McGann were in a
position to know more about Porter than
they have acknowledged this is deciding
whether or not to hire someone House
Oversight Committee Chairman trey Gowdy
launched an investigation into White
House decisions on Porter's employment
and security clearance saying he wants
answers from Kelly and Magan I cannot
fathom how someone if they had access to
this information and the photographs
could extend an offer an employment to
someone with this in their background
some media outlets reported the number
of White House staffers with an interim
security clearance was more than 100
including Magan Plus Ivanka Trump and
Jared Kushner interim security clearance
is for lower-level administration
officials are not uncommon even after
all this time in office but it would be
highly unusual Gale for top White House
officials to not have all security
clearance and background check questions
resolved all right major thank you very
much